die Metro von rakif ist ein Symbol des
Widerstands der Ukrainer gegen die
russische Aggression hier hatten die
Menschen während der schlimmsten
Angriffe Zuflucht gesucht jetzt wollen
sie ihren jüngsten eine sichere Lernwelt
bieten es ist ein aufregender erster
Schultag für die sechsjährigen und ihre
Lehrer aber jeden Tag können Sie hier
unten nicht unterrichten dafür reicht
der Platz nicht sie wechseln sich ab
sind mal im Online-Unterricht zu Hause
oder hier jedes Kind soll wenigstens
manchmal normalen Unterricht haben
mal für uns ist das als könnten wir
endlich wieder frische Luft atmen denn
für die Kinder ist das doch schlimm zu
Hause alleine zu lernen die Eltern mögen
das auch nicht sie wollen dass Sie hier
mindestens zweimal in der Woche hinter
ihren Schultaschen sitzen und alle
zusammen lernen
ich kann sie bei der Hand nehmen und
ihnen zeigen wie jemand schreibt
das ist doch ein viel emotionaler Umgang
miteinander als durch einen Monitor
die Ukraine will den knapp vier
Millionen Schülerinnen und Schülern im
Land so viel regulären Unterricht bieten
wie möglich doch und die Hälfte wird
immer wieder von zu Hause lernen müssen
solange Krieg ist luisa hat heute die
ersten Buchstaben gelernt das hat sie
ein bisschen müde gemacht aber einen
Traumberuf weil sie jetzt schon
wir haben etwas gelernt und ein bisschen
gebastelt wenn ich groß bin möchte ich
Lehrerin werden
rakip die Stadt an der Grenze zu
Russland wird immer wieder beschossen
oft heule in die Sirenen hier unten
bekommen sie davon nichts mit höre nicht
einmal die U-Bahn fahren und atmen auch
keine dicke Luft
ich bin froh dass das System zum
Luftaustausch hier unten so gut
funktioniert
und trotz der sommerlichen Temperaturen
draußen ist es hier drin doch ganz
angenehm
der erste Schultag hat Luisa ganz viel
Spaß gemacht mit ihrer neuen Klasse
sitzt sie im Bus nach Hause das Schul
Halstuch ist noch ein bisschen ungewohnt
ein paar Reihen hinter ihnen Lehrerin
Hanna sie tröstet Schüler denen der
Schulbeginn nicht so viel Spaß gemacht
hat wie Luisa und ihrer Freundin dass
die Lehrerin im Bus mitfährt hat mit dem
Krieg zu tun
das ist jetzt mal eine ganz andere
Gelegenheit die Kinder kennenzulernen
ich frage sie was sie mögen und was sie
gerne machen
mache mir ein paar geistige Notizen und
arbeite praktisch im Bus weiter
hier können wir ganz ruhig über unsere
Eindrücke sprechen es geht nicht um
Schule sondern über das Leben allgemein
die Eltern warten vor der eigentlichen
Schule schon sehnsüchtig auf den Bus mit
Lehrerinnen und den Schulanfängern aus
dem Bunker
auf dem Heimweg hat Luisa ihre Mutter
Holger viel zu erzählen die beiden leben
alleine der Krieg hat die kleine Familie
auseinandergerissen
mein Mann ist Bulgare da war es schnell
klar für uns wohin wir flüchten als zu
Kriegsbeginn morgens um elf die ersten
Granaten detonierten sind wir dorthin
aufgebrochen wie alle anderen dachten
wir wir verreisen nur für ein paar Tage
am Ende waren wir über ein Jahr dort
zurückgekommen in die alte Wohnung mit
den Erinnerungen an das Familienleben
vor dem Krieg ist sie weil sie einen Job
an der Universität hat und Luisa
unbedingt in der Ukraine einschulen
wollte
ohne den Krieg hätte meine ältere
Tochter ihre kleine Schwester natürlich
bei der Hand genommen und zur
Einschulung begleitet so wie das
Tradition ist
aber sie ist ein Bulgarien geblieben
wollte den Sommer nicht hier verbringen
da drüben geht es dir besser
sie hat Freunde dort
Luisa und ihre Mutter haben ständig
Kontakt zu der 16-Jährigen Milena die
auf jeden Fall zum Studium zurückkommen
möchte
[Musik]
wir Ukrainer sind sehr stark und das
sogar in diesen harten Zeiten wir finden
immer einen Weg zu lernen und den
Kontakt zu halten trotz all dem ich bin
ganz sicher wir werden alle wieder nach
Hause kommen und gemeinsam die Ukraine
stark machen
Luisa sehnt sich danach dass ihre
Schwester irgendwann wieder zurück nach
Hause kommt heute allerdings freut sie
sich darüber dass sie schon weiß was sie
einmal unterrichten möchte
darin werden für Englisch oder
Französisch für alle Sprachen der ganzen
Welt die Aussicht so viel lernen zu
können bereitet ihr ganz viel Freude
ganz gleich ob Krieg ist oder nicht